The oath establishing the 30 years peace was worn in the year 45,
four 45 and that leaves,
as we know,
of course they didn't uh,
oh about 14 years before the Great Peloponnesian war will break out.
Uh,
and although we only know a little bit about the events between the two wars,
uh,
what we do know I think is interesting,
although not easy to interpret evidence about the character of that piece,
which we've been talking about
one way to determine whether the piece was a true piece with a real chance of
lasting and controlling it to national affairs for a good long time for whether
it was really a truce that merely interrupted a conclusion to a war that was
inevitable.
I think that can be tested to some degree by the events that took place in those
14 years or so.
I think we can be one critical question of course,
is a quite apart from the objective elements of the piece,
maybe more important than those are the intentions of the two sides.
And I think it is perfect.
It is possible to arrive at some sense of what that those intentions were.
There is little doubt that Paris [inaudible] still in the position of the
leading politician in Athens.
Clearly the man who was the,
uh,
I think the,
the negotiator for peace on the Athenians side,
if I'm right about his invention of the arbitration clause,
um,
that would suggest he was very much personally involved in shaping the character
of that piece.
It seems plain that he really was sincerely committed to a policy of preserving
peace for the future,
for as far as it could possibly go.
One reason is that several years before the peace and d before this war had
broken out,
the Athenians had made a piece with the king of Persia.
The negotiator on the Athenian side was a man named Cali ass.
And so it goes down in the book,
says the peace of Calculus.
This is about as debated as subject as there is in the history of ancient
Greece.
Was there really a piece of [inaudible] or not?
Was it a formal piece or not?
Even in ancient times.
Some writers question whether this was a historical fact.
I won't trouble you with all the arguments both ways,
but let me,
let me indicate my own opinion is that there actually was a formal piece,
but it doesn't matter whether that's true or false because nobody doubts that
there was a de facto peace between the Athenians and their allies on the one
hand and the Persians for a good long time.
And that it is not broken until well into the Great Peloponnesian war.
When in the year for 12,
there is a treaty made between Sparta and Persia,
which brings pleasure into the war against the Athenians.
So there's this considerable stretch of time when there is peace with Persia.
Now
about the same time,
roughly the year,
it's the traditional date for piece of Kelly's is four 49 and about the same
time we are told only by Plutarch's.
So some scholars have question the historicity of this too,
that Pericles has called for a great panhellenic Congress could discuss a
variety of questions,
but one of them was,
uh,
how shall we keep the prem promises we made after the Persian war to rebuild the
temples to the gods that had been destroyed by the Persians in that war?
And how shall we see to the freedom of the seas
now?
Um,
the question of course,
the,
uh,
the temples of the gods that had been destroyed and the Persian war,
we're essentially all in Attica.
So that here was a,
an occasion wherever the Athenians allegedly or apparently hoping to bring all
the Greeks into the picture to help pay the cost of restoring those temples.
It wasn't as Indians who had benefited from it most,
but also maintaining the freedom of the seas meant providing for a fleet that
would keep the Persians out and keep pirates out and so on.
You Athenians obviously had that fleet,
the result of having the,
if the Greeks had all in fact participated in this activity,
it would have been a way of legitimizing both the Athenian Empire.
And of course the navy that made it great,
but also it would have legitimized the plan that Pericles had in mind in which
we know he carried out to the best of his ability immediately to rebuild those
temples and indeed to build some new ones as well on the Acropolis and elsewhere
in Attica as evidence of the greatness and the glory of Athens.
This building program was going to be at the center of his domestic concerns for
the rest of the period,
but talking about he invited all the Greeks,
but as it turned out,
the Spartans and their friends chose not to show up.
You can see why for the reasons that I in fact just given you as to why this
would be attractive to Athens.
That's why it would not be attractive to Sparta.
There is some debate.
Did Perricone is ever expect that the Spartans would accept or was this just his
way of making it clear that since the Spartans and the other Greeks would not
participate in these activities,
Athens was right in going about it unilaterally.
One of the things that it would do if the Athenians were now to say,
well,
this at,
when the Spartans didn't show up in their lives,
didn't show up.
He said,
if they won't keep their promises to the gods,
we will.
That provides justification for building the first of the great temples he was
going to put up on the Acropolis,
the Parthenon,
which was going to be the great marvel of the Greek world,
uh,
thereafter,
and which was going to be very expensive and which he was going to use league
money for.
This would legitimize it.
He hoped and it would be,
uh,
an argument for doing that as for the,
claim that they needed to preserve the freedom of the seas,
that would be a legit give legitimacy to the existence of the Athenian,
uh,
of the great fleet of the League,
which was paid for by league money.
In other words,
it would give legitimacy to the Athenian Empire.
No doubt.
He thought that was necessary because having made of either,
that's why I liked the idea that he did make a formal piece with the Persians.
But in either case with it being obvious that there would be no more attacks on
the Persians,
that the uh,
and the Persians were out and that they were not a threat anymore.
Why should the ally's contribute their ships and money?
And by the way,
by this time,
most of them were not contributing money and the Athenians had ma,
we're manning all of the fleet.
Why should this continue?
If the war with the Persians was over,
Perry,
please never imagined that the Athenians would give up their fleet,
their empire,
the tribute that supported all of that.
So he needed to have a reason for doing it.
And so my view and that of many other scholars is that the congress decree is,
it is called certainly had that as a motive.
Was He serious?
What would he have done if the Spartans had said,
sure,
we'll do that.
I think he expected that they wouldn't,
but he was prepared to have them do that because if they would,
they would contribute the money presumably that was necessary.
And they would also grant legitimacy to what the Athenians were doing with their
navy at sea.
And of course it would be a wonderful situation because it would create a kind
of a unity between the two that would help keep wore away and Pericles his plan
for using all of that money from the Treasury for his building program required
piece.
If the Athenians are going to be at war,
that money would not be available.
So for all of these reasons he did what he did.
My guess is he the anticipated the likely outcome and a that,
but it doesn't mean that he was unprepared to deal with the situation if it had
been otherwise.
There I think we see the first bit of evidence that leads to my own opinion that
pair Buckley's was very sincere about preserving the the 30 years peace that he
saw that and hoped it would be the instrument by which there would be,
you know,
who can talk about perpetual piece but at least piece for the foreseeable
future.
Another event that a much debated one that cast some light on what's going on
occurs in the year four 43
in that year,
the Athenians agreed to help establish a colony in southern Italy.
At a place that they called [inaudible].
Now,
there are several things about this colony that are interesting and perhaps,
uh,
as,
as interesting as any is that it was different from any other colony we ever
heard of in the Greek world before this time.
You know,
the picture of what a typical appboy Kia is light.
It is the colony of a city and that city is its mother city.
And you know all about those relationships.
There were rare occasions where a couple of cities might get together and
jointly be the mother's cities of a town,
but that's all.
This colony was established from the first as a Pan Hel linic colony.
In other words,
it was not an Athenian Colony,
even though the Athenians took the lead in establishing a colony,
even though the Athenians,
uh,
appointed the critical players in establishing the colony,
the founder,
the oil kist was an Athenian paraclese sent along,
uh,
the leading sear,
the leading religious figure in all of Athens to be a helpful in the founding of
that city.
Uh,
Hurghada tests,
a good friend of [inaudible] who also of course was the father of history,
went out there presumably to be the historian of the new city.
Um,
what's an epididymus the great city planner of the fifth century BC who was
famous.
You might not think this is such a big deal,
but it is.
He,
he,
uh,
applied simply right angled streets in founding the new city when of course,
all the old cities had been founded,
as I described,
Athens itself with streets that just developed out of old cow paths that just
wound all over the place.
So the modern grid structure was the work of Hipaa.
Damos.
Uh,
all of these guys were friends and associates.
Part of the brains trust you might say of,
uh,
Athens under paraclese and these guys went out and established the colony of a
3I.
All of these elements are interesting.
Why a panhellenic colony?
Well,
for one thing,
uh,
I should point out too,
that Pericles has had seen to it that the membership of the colony consisted of
people from a variety of places.
And it's interesting to point out that although the Athenians had the greatest
single number of people in this new colony,
when that colony's constitution was drawn up,
I forgot,
um,
what's the name of the Sophos?
The Protagoras laid out the constitution for this a new city.
Again,
he was a friend of Paraclese.
It was divided up into 10 tribes,
just like Athens.
It was a democracy.
The constitution was very much influenced by the Athenian model,
and
as I say,
one of the 10 tribes,
and remember the 10 tribes have to be equal in order for them to present the
necessary regiments in the army.
Only one 10th of the people were Athenians,
even though there were more Athenians than anybody else.
But there were several tribes made up of Peloponnesians,
not from one particular city,
but all from the Peloponnesus.
I make those points because I want to make it clear that if you just look at the
percentage of the population occupied by Athenians,
it will not allow them to dominate the city.
This really is a Pan Helina colony.
Why?
My view is that [inaudible] was attempting to make a very significant point
here.
After all this,
this colony was established in reaction to a request made by some Italian Greeks
who were having trouble in their own city,
needed to found a new one,
needed more people in order to make it viable.
Went to Spartan.
The Spartan said,
we're not interested.
Went to Athens to the Athenians said,
yes,
we'll help you do this.
Now the Athenians could have said no or they could have done the normal thing if
they wanted to say yes,
make it an Athenian colony.
Why did they come up with this brand new idea that nobody had ever seen?
In my view,
it was because [inaudible] was glad to have an opportunity to demonstrate
something about Athens intentions now and in the future.
That was the best way to advertise the fact that the Athenians were not
interested in expanding their power out to the west because if they had been,
they would have made it an Athenian colony.
Other scholars have taken the opposite view and think it is a sign of Athenian
imperial interest,
which would have said practically the day after the treaty was signed,
Paris Lees and the Athenians were already,
uh,
violating the spirit of that treaty.
But I think that is easily demonstrated to be wrong.
All we have to do it well,
first of all,
what I've done already is to look at the internal character of the state.
And you want to argue that is not the way to start an imperial venture in the
West,
set up a colony that's not your colony.
And that has only got a 10th of its population being Athenian.
But other evidence I think makes it all the clearer.
Uh,
only a year after the foundation of the city,
it went to war against a neighboring town,
the town of Tara Os,
which became the Roman town of Tarentum modern Toronto.
Tal Ross was one of the only spartan colonies.
So here you have a spartan colony fighting against and it's [inaudible],
whatever that is.
Imagine for a moment though,
it were an Athenian colony as the people of a different view.
Say,
what does Athens do?
I think that's really critical.
The answer is nothing.
Tara's defeats Suriani then to rub it in,
they take some of the spoils of victory and place them at the,
uh,
at Olympia,
whether you were,
the Games are held,
where all the Greeks can come and see in which they boast about their victory
over three.
I know what it is he needs to do about all this.
Nothing.
This is not the way to behave if you're planning to start an empire in Sicily
and southern Italy.
So I think that's a very serious blow to the theory of imperialism out there.
And then a few years down the road,
we get to the year for 34,
three,
the crisis which will produce the Great Peloponnesian war has already begun.
So everybody is looking ahead to the coming war between Athens and Sparta at
that time.
There is a,
uh,
a big argument breaks out within three I,
who's colony are we once again,
a terrific indication that nobody thinks it's an Athenian colony right off the
bat.
Although in the argument the Athenians claim,
well it's in the Athenian colony.
I mean the Athenians in three,
I say we're in an Athenian colony because there are more Athenians than anybody
else upon the Peloponnesian say,
yes,
there are more things than anybody else,
but there are more Peloponnesians and there are Athenians.
So we are a Peloponnesian colony.
We are a spartan colony.
Well,
they couldn't agree and so they came to the decision that they would allow,
um,
Apollo through his article at Delphi to decide.
And then that's an interesting thing to who does the Oracle at Delphi lean
towards?
We've had very clear evidence of it in the four forties.
They are pro Spartans.
The Spartans have been the defenders of the priest as against the functions from
the outside.
There's every reason to believe a decision made by the priest of Apollo will
favor Sparta and it,
that's not what happens though.
What the priest says,
you are not an Athenian colony and not a spartan colony.
You are,
my colony says Apollo,
very nice way out of the fixed.
But one thing they're not isn't Athenian colony.
Now,
what are those imperialist Athenians do about it?
Nothing to my mind that absolutely undercuts any claim that Athenian
imperialism,
the West explains what's going on out there,
but why?
What's going on out there old together?
Why did he establish it at all?
Why did these established it in the way that he did and why did he react or not
react in the way that he did?
My suggestion for which there is no ancient direct evidence is it was meant
specifically at buy to use a current modern terms.
This was a diplomatic signal.
Paraclese wanted the rest of the world and most especially the Spartans in their
palpitation allies to know that Athens did not have ambitions of expanding their
empire onto the mainland or out west.
I think what was understood by the 30 years pieces,
the Athenian Empire as it exists in an editor,
I'm sorry,
in the Aegean and its trunk boundaries and to the East in the direction of
Persia,
that's the Athenian sphere of influence.
Again,
to use a modern term,
everything to the west of that these needs are going to stay out of and leave
alone.
And my view is [inaudible] delivered that message in his behavior and concerning
theory.
And he would have known,
I believe that the number one state who would be concerned about what was
happening out west would be current because the Corinthian chain of colonies and
the Corinthian major area of commerce was in the West,
Italy,
Sicily and such.
And so it was the Corinthians,
I think,
whom to whom he meant to send this message.
And in a little while we'll see how that works out.
Uh,
how that,
uh,
whether it worked or it did not,
but it seems to me that is the only way to understand these events that I have
been putting together.
But having said that,
I remind you that other scholars don't understand it that way.
This takes us to the year for 40,
when another critical event,
uh,
tests the piece,
the island of Samos is,
has been an oligarchy gray.
It has been one of the biggest states in the empire.
It is,
uh,
it has been autonomous.
That is to say it has its own fleet,
its own government,
which is again,
all the Gar kick,
not democratic.
The way most of the states are when the Athenians conquer them.
Uh,
but the,
and in that state,
there was a rebellion.
It comes about because of a quarrel between the Samians an island.
I remind you very close to the coast of Asia minor and the town of my leaders,
that famous city of philosophers,
which is just across from Samos and in between the two on the mainland is a very
small town called Trion.
He,
me and each town,
each one of these states claims,
uh,
priority.
So it's a classic,
a quarrel between Greek polies about territory that's between them.
Now this presents a very special problem to the Athenians when you think about
it.
On the one hand,
the Athenians hardly want to get into a fight with Samos,
an island of great power and importance with whom they have been associated for
a very long time.
On the other hand,
how can the,
uh,
had germinal power of an alliance allow the big fish in the alliance to eat the
little fish,
which is what would be happening here.
That is an unacceptable,
if you're going to have a proper,
had germinal relationship with these folks.
So the Athenians tried to,
um,
sort of split the difference as best they could.
They offered to serve as arbitrators in this dispute and thereby to avoid war,
uh,
Samos would not hear of it.
The same means of course expected to beat my latest and they would have done
that.
They were in the process of doing what they were doing,
asserting true autonomy as against the Athenian version of it in the past.
But the Athenians couldn't permit that.
It's again,
one of these confrontations in which each side,
from its own perspective has right on its side.
But these two concepts of right are inevitably in conflict and problems occur.
Well,
the Athenians when they are told that they,
uh,
Samians attorney down the arbitrators and they're fighting against the,
my lesions,
Perricone is immediately puts a fleet together and sales across the sea and puts
down the rebellion by force.
And then he takes the steps that the Athenians have typically taken against
rebellious states over the last decades.
That is he establishes a democracy,
put an end to the previous regime.
He takes hostages from the rebellious aristocrats or all oligarchy and settles
them on a nearby island to be sure that these people will behave.
Um,
other than that he imposes on them an easy settlement.
He does not do any great,
just does not do any harm to anybody as an execute anybody.
It doesn't take away people's land,
doesn't to exile all kinds of folks.
He doesn't do that.
Uh,
and so his expectation,
and I guess his hope would have been that that would be that from now on,
saint must would be a democracy and therefore reliable and friendly.
And there would be no further trouble.
The,
the hostages would help make that secure.
But the defeated oligarchs did not accept defeat.
They went to the Persian sat trap inland from [inaudible].
His name was [inaudible] and asked for his help and he gave it,
he sent a force in.
The first thing they did was to go to the island with the hostages were kept.
Take those hostages back and return them to their friends and families and
thereby took away this restraint against further trouble.
And now the Samians overthrew the democratic regime that had just been placed in
power and started a an oligarchic revolution.
Now that's very serious right away,
but more serious than that is on the news that this had happened.
The city of Bizarre Santiam,
which became constant and Opa,
which became Istanbul,
located at this vital strategic place on the Bosphorus also rebuild.
We are told later on into cities that at some time,
and he doesn't date it,
uh,
the,
um,
island of Middle Ini,
another one of these big independent important states with,
with a navy also,
uh,
was thinking about rebellion.
And I go along with those scholars who suggest this is the time when they were
doing their thinking.
So Athens is suddenly confronted by a danger that they have really not faced
before.
On the one hand,
their empire may be in general rebellion soon if this thing spreads.
Secondly,
the Persians have actually taken an aggressive step against the Athenian Empire
by assisting the Samians in their rebellion.
Now we don't know and the Athenians couldn't know whether [inaudible] had acted
in accordance with the instructions of the great king or at least the wishes of
the great king or he was just running an independent operation.
The first would be a very,
very serious problem.
Indeed.
It would mean a major threat from Persia.
The second would still be moderately serious.
I think we have to,
we can't be sure because there was no time for herself needs to consult the king
and everything's happening.
Bang,
and it takes months to get to a a message back to Susan where the great king
list,
so it's in the first instance with Stephanie's a certainly acting on his own.
The question is,
does he,
does he really know how the king will react or not?
We can only guess about that,
but here we go.
There are two,
two parts of the trinity that will mean disaster for athletes.
If we look ahead to the Peloponnesian war and examine,
what was it that defeated Athens and put an end to their empire.
It was the combination of rebellion in the empire,
assistance to the rebellions by the Persians.
And the third critical step of course,
was that the Spartans were also in the war and ready to,
and in fact they did invade Attica and against the Athenians on land.
And it's that third critical element that is decisive right now here in four 40
the Spartans call a meeting of the Peloponnesian League to discuss the question
of should we make war on the Athenians at this time?
And that would consist of invading Attica and had they done so we would have
had,
as I say,
what was necessary to defeat Athens in the great war.
Now we know later on when the final crisis in four 32 and four 31 33 actually is
when did the speech I'm referring to takes place
a critical part of the story of bringing on that war was the attitude of the
Corinthians.
As we shall see.
The Corinthians in four 30 starting in four 33 at least began agitating for war.
And their agitation,
I will argue,
played a critical role in bringing the Spartans to fight.
What do they do now?
On that occasion when they were,
uh,
on the brink of war,
the Corinthians went to Athens and try to argue the Athenians out of taking
steps that the Corinthians thought would push the war into reality.
And they said this,
why when the Samians revolted from you and the other Peloponnesians were divided
in their votes on the question of aiding them,
we on our part did not vote against you.
On the contrary,
we openly maintain that each one should discipline his own allies without
interference.
Now that's critical.
What they're saying is there would have been an agreement to go and attack
Athens.
We stopped.
It was their assertion.
Now that statement cannot be as simple outright lie cause the Athenians and
everybody else in the Greek world by now would have known what happened in that
meeting.
Possibly they're exaggerating their role,
but what they can not be doing is misrepresenting the position they took against
the war with spark.
My question is,
why were the Corinthians and who are so annoyed by the Athenians?
Remember it was there the Athenian alliance with mega against Carnes and about
four 61,
four 60 that started the belt first Peloponnesian war.
And as the city's tells us,
uh,
was the source of the hatred of the Corinthians for the Athenians.
And yet here we are in for 40 and they are making a critical position against
the war.
My answer to that question is thorough AI.
I believe that when Pericles and the Athenians sent that diplomatic message,
the Corinthians received it,
thought they understood it and it changed their policies.
So long as the Athenians stayed out of their bailiwick,
they were prepared to preserve the peace.
So I think that's a very important story if you agree with that,
uh,
analogy piece was very rigorously tested and for 40 and peace one out over a
tremendous temptation to go to war.
That leads me to believe that peace was possible.
And I would argue still further that having passed this great crisis,
having passed this test,
chances of peace,
we're better than ever because the two sides had acquired reason to trust the
other,
to behave by the rules as they had been established.
There is one small point,
but which turns out not to be so small,
which I'll come back to,
which is the Corinthians interpretation of precisely what that piece meant I
think will turn out to be not exactly what the Athenians thought that it meant.
And that would be serious when we get down to the final crisis.
But in four 40,
my assertion is the same in rebellion demonstrates that war is still not
necessary.
What has been established in the minds of both sides.
This I think is perfectly clear,
is what we would call in the modern world a balance of power in which the two
sides recognize the other really as equals where each has established a sphere
of influence,
uh,
out of which the other is to stay.
And that,
uh,
this is a satisfactory,
the Spartans,
you know,
the,
the issue about the Spartans and the argument about their behavior at this time
comes down to this.
One scholar wants to emphasize the fact that the Ecet Spartans even thought
about going to war against the Athenians.
And if that hadn't been true,
they never would have been a meeting of the Peloponnesian League.
That's true.
He takes their decision to call the league as evidence that they had decided to
go to war and were talked out of it by the Corinthians and their allies.
That's not the way I see it.
I think that the Spartans in for 40 were in the same position they were in,
or I will argue they were in a,
at the beginning of the Peloponnesian war,
divided,
uncertain.
The more aggressive Spartans were tempted by the terrific opportunity,
the same Ian War presented,
the more conservative and traditional Spartans were,
uh,
reluctant to start another big war against the Athenians.
And the Hawks had enough power to compel them to consult their allies.
But how they realized reacted was going to be decisive.
And so I think that,
uh,
my,
my reading of it is that the conservative Spartans where normally the majority
of the Spartans and it took a very special set of circumstances,
a special set of conditions that to move to Spartans,
to war,
and the Corinthians saw to it that that was not going to happen.
Be warned.
All of this is a matter of interpretation.
There is no certainty about it.
And,
uh,
and through Sydney's himself who I think and most people would agree,
thinks that the wall was going to come anyway regardless.
Uh,
he doesn't express opinions about these actions that I'm talking about as to
whether they did or did not influence the course of events.
But we have that evidence and we have to use it and think about it.
My conclusion then is after,
uh,
the Athenians are now free to put down the rebellions at Samos and at Byzantium
to restore their empire and they will use the remaining years before the final
crisis to strengthen their control of the Aegean Sea.
And if the empire in the east,
again,
some scholars who think the war inevitable,
um,
we'll say this strengthening of the empire was in fact itself a growth of
Athenian power.
And that seems to me to be a great stretch of,
of the understanding of that word.
What it is,
is a consolidation of what they already have.
And there is no evidence that the,
uh,
these actions that I'm talking about,
frightened the Spartans are upset them.
And,
and that's worth a lot because we hear plenty of complaints about what the
Athenians are doing in the final crisis.
Uh,
and,
but nobody makes any reference to these events that some scholars think show
Athenian,
uh,
growth.
So there we are again,
a crisis has been overcome.
My argument is no reason in the world why the two sides should fight each other.
And,
uh,
in the absence of some new thing that changes circumstances that brings us down
precisely to the final crisis.
So I've been telling you the war is not inevitable.
So now I have to tell Ya,
why did it happen?
And that's what I'll try to do.
It starts where the acidities of course shortly begins the story having told you
the story of how Athens came to be an empire,
how Athens and Sparta came to divide grease between them in that first portion
of his history.
In Book One,
we get to what I think is a chapter 24 and the first book where he suddenly
moves to where the crisis begins.
And where does it begin?
It begins in a town called Epi dampness,
which is located on the western shore of the Greek peninsula on the Ionian Sea.
It is,
um,
I'm trying to remember what was the,
Oh yeah,
it was called,
uh,
was it the rock him
Curtis,
is that right?
Yeah.
Can,
uh,
in Roman times it was called to rock him.
It was on,
uh,
an important road system that they had,
but in Greek times it was out nowhere is what I'm trying to suggest to you.
It was not even on the way to anything very important.
It was,
um,
I always,
I'm reminded of the term that Neville Chamberlain used when suddenly war
threatened about a place in the middle of Europe called Czechoslovakia and
Chamberlain set about it,
a place a far away place of which we know nothing.
I would have been embarrassed to say that even in 1937
a but it's really something about epidem is,
I mean it's,
it's out way out there in the middle of nowhere.
As far as the Greeks are concerned,
nothing is important about epic dampness itself.
This is one of the many occasions in which great wars start in places that are
inherently insignificant,
but certain aspects of the situation make them significant.
In this case,
the most important aspect was that Epidem,
this had been founded by a course Syrah,
the modern island of Corfu located not too far to the south of this.
By the way,
I should have told you that the town of ancient epidem this today is in Albania
and it's,
I can't pronounce,
I don't know how,
how Banians pronounced things,
but my best attempt is duress,
but I'm not sure that's right.
D U.
R.
E.
S.
Anyway,
um,
the,
uh,
of course Koreans established the colony there centuries ago,
but of course IRA was a colony itself of currents.
But as I told you early in the semester,
it was a very unusual colony.
It's relations with the mother city where most unusual,
they,
a facility's reports that the first trireme battle in all of history was fought
between car and thin core Syrah in the seventh century.
And there are repeated wars between current and core Cyra just about one a
century,
sometimes more frequently.
And it's very clear that by the time we are into the fourth thirties,
these two cities hate each other and they hate each other with a traditional
hatred handed on down from century to century.
This is a very critical part of comprehending what takes place here
anyway,
sometime maybe around four 36,
a civil war breaks out within the city of epidem.
This in what is not unusual by now in the Greek world,
it's about Democrats versus oligarchs.
And the a
one side has control of the city.
The other side is driven into exile.
The exiles,
uh,
get help from the barbarian tribes in the neighborhood because we're really
talking about the frontier of the Greek world.
They are not surrounded by fellow Greeks.
They are surrounded by non Greeks.
So,
um,
they're,
they are when the people who are besieged
send a delegation to their mothers city,
of course,
siren asking for help from course Syrah in bringing peace to the city,
uh,
and in putting an end to the siege,
which they are experiencing it.
Well the course Syrians are not interested.
They're answer is no,
we don't want to help you.
Uh,
there's no evidence.
They care about which side wins they are simply being,
uh,
they see no point in getting involved themselves.
And important part of the story of course,
Syrah and its significance in the becoming of the war is that it was neutral
towards everybody.
It was not a part of the Peloponnesian Confederation.
It was not part of the Athenian League and it wasn't associated with anybody
else.
In fact,
it had a reputation,
if you can believe the Corinthians of being terribly uppity and associating with
anybody.
I guess if you ask the course around,
he might have used a lot Saul's term for Great Britain late in the 19th century
as enjoying splendid isolation.
It wasn't too many years before Lord Saulsbury and others realized that
isolation wasn't so splendid as they thought.
And so it was with core Syrah.
But for the moment of course,
the,
and saying,
who the hell cares?
Who Wins?
You're stupid civil war.
Take a walk.
So they did,
well,
I shouldn't say they took a boat ride.
Uh,
they went to carts.
Now this demonstrates an incredibly important principle of human behavior.
What do you do if you go to mother and you ask her,
can I have the keys to the car or whatever it is you need.
And she says,
no,
you'll go to grandma.
You know what grandma will say?
Right?
You know the old story about the grandmother who somebody breasts rushes up,
tells the grandmother,
uh,
your grandson has just taken a neighbor's child and throw him out of a third,
thrown him out of a third floor window.
Grandmother says,
blessons such strong hands.
So,
uh,
the Corinthians react as grandmother Mike,
that is to say they agree to send help to the besieged.
Um,
epidem Ian's,
they also agree to send an army,
which,
uh,
the first day we'll send a fleet,
then they'll send an army which will go there as well.
And they are also are willing to,
uh,
colony recolonize the city because of course the city is now divided between two
sides.
So if they're going to,
if the people inside are going to win the war,
ultimately they're going to need new citizens.
They're not going to want to take back those people trying to kill him.
So the Athenian,
the currency is organized a new colony to join them.
In other words,
they give them every kind of help than anybody can imagine.
Now,
if we look for a reason why the Corinthians should have been willing to make
this enormous contribution to this faraway argument,
scholars have had a field day for centuries trying to figure out what the
tangible benefits are with absolutely no look,
there is no evidence of that is persuasive at all.
That there are economic benefits to current that are significant if they somehow
have control,
no matter what style control of Epidem this.
And so I think we are driven back
as we should have been driven in the first place.
Does there acidities explanation who himself asks the question and answers it
about the whole quarrel between cards and of course Syrah.
And he refers simply to the hatred that the Corinthians felt towards the course
of readings.
When you get to that passage to take a good look at it,
uh,
because [inaudible] understands that we're all gonna raise our eyebrows a bit.
And so he tells us a tale.
Why is that?
So?
He says,
because every year the Corinthians hold a religious festival in their city to
which all of their allies sending delegates,
this is very normal.
And all the other delegates treat them as you should treat a mother city with
deference,
with respect,
with gratitude,
with kindness.
What through the course of eons,
do they abuse them publicly?
They,
they call them names,
they treat them like dirt.
They insult them in front of all of the,
uh,
in front of the family,
so to speak.
And therefore the Corinthians hate them.
And out of this furious dislike that that is what their actions are about.
This has made scholars in the modern world very nervous.
They understand that there are only two things that make people fight one
another.
One of,
well,
yeah,
that's pretty much what they used to say now that I think of it,
and many of them still do in the face of what we see in the world today,
uh,
one is money that is economic gain.
Thank we can thank marks for that.
And for a whole century or more,
people couldn't understand that people ever do anything for any reason except
for monetary gain.
There isn't anything in this to explain it.
It just won't do no scholars.
They failed and attempting to show how that might be true.
The other has to do with power.
Uh,
you know,
relationships.
Uh,
if you,
if you have this state on your side,
it will give the balance of power to you and so on.
But the truth of the matter is the epidemic,
this is essentially irrelevant to the ordinary struggles of power between these
two states at Corinth and,
uh,
and uh,
of course,
IRA,
Ira won't be poorer.
It won't be weaker if the Corinthians have epidemic.
Uh,
nor is there some kind of a tremendous strategic edge if you can launch your
attack from epidem this rather than from someplace else.
No,
no.
There's no reason to doubt two acidities about this.
This is about honor and it's about dishonor.
Now,
does that sound very remote?
Who Cares about honor and 20th century,
21st Century?
What,
what kind of nonsense is this?
I will tell you that you and everybody around you and everything you see in the
world today is motivated more frequently,
especially in conflict,
but other things too.
The way you lead your life is influenced more by considerations of honor then of
anything else.
If some,
and let me put it in the way that is most helpful in this context.
It's really the negative that's important.
More important than honor is dishonor.
People hate to be dishonored.
They hate.
There was a wonderful slang word that now tells the story.
It wasn't available when I was a kid.
The thing was available,
but the word wasn't available.
If I say to you,
he dismayed.
Do you know what I mean?
Do you think there's a danger to your teeth if you just the wrong guy?
Do you doubt that that sort of thing motivates individual people constantly?
And I can show you an already shown the world that uh,
it motivates nations constantly today,
not only 20 years ago or 500 years ago,
2000 years ago.
That's what the acidities is showing us here.
This is a very important permanent truth.
This is why their cities is so superior to modern political scientists studying
international relations.
They don't understand these things and two cities did.
So that I think is what is happening.
And when it becomes clear to core Syrah,
that currents is involved,
that they are looking for a fight and that they have dishonored course Syrah by
taking over one of their colonies.
The cost marines are on the one hand angered,
but on the other hand,
they're frightened because current is a great,
powerful state and more important than that current is one of the most
significant allies of Sparta.
If the Corinthians are giving us grief,
the Costa Ricans could think this is a prelude to having the Peloponnesian
League come after us.
And that is not something you want to happen.
So the course of [inaudible] ask for a conference with the Corinthians and uh,
they come and say,
let's let us find a way to make peace over this issue.
Let's see how we can negotiate.
A piece of Corinthians are adamant.
They say,
you want peace.
This is what you've got to do.
You have got to withdraw your forces from the city.
Here you are B,
uh,
besieging the city.
And uh,
let me see if they're riding the Chris,
of course the rains have come with their fleet.
They have defeated the uh,
you know,
I've been,
I always get this so backwards.
Let me see if I've got this right.
What are the core server Ian's doing?
Curtis?
Are they on the side of the guys inside or outside?
Do you remember?
You're on the inside.
Yeah,
that's right.
But they have now of their armies are in the field and they're navy is at see
against the opposition to the folks are inside the city and um,
so the currency and say you are,
you're finding these people and you're asking us to talk peace while you're
fighting these people.
You're withdrawing your people and then we'll talk peace.
Well of course that would give the advantage to the other side and the coverage
of course.
Reagan said no way and tell you what,
we'll withdraw our people if you withdraw your people.
Corinthians said,
no way.
I think what comes out of this back and forth is important.
It's it is that the course of [inaudible] are not looking to expand this fight.
They want to end it not because they're peaceful and lovable fellows,
but because they're afraid of where this thing will go.
We are now dealing with another term that came into fruition in the 20th
century.
Escalation is what these guys were afraid of.
We've got this little fight going on here,
but next thing you know,
we may find the Peloponnesian League involved,
but the Corinthians clearly aren't worried about that and that's going to be a
point we have to cope with.
They,
um,
mmm.
Right.
The current,
the course serines say,
look,
if you don't work this out with us now,
we may have to seek allies,
other allies besides those.
We already have wealth.
Who cities has told us they don't have any other allies,
but who are these allies that they're going to seek?
That's a real question.
Somebody telling me.
Yeah.
Athens,
of course.
I wanted you to tell me,
because I want to emphasize how obvious it is.
Nobody could have missed the signal.
This is a threat.
We know you Corinthians are playing as tough as you are because you're counting
on the Spartans to assist you.
Well,
if you do,
we will ask the Athenians to help us and then what?
And so the,
the situation goes forward.
The Corinthians are not bluffed.
If it was really a bluff and uh,
uh,
on they go,
mmm.
It by,
I should point out that at this,
um,
meeting the course serines said they were willing to submit this quarrel to
arbitration.
I remind you again,
not mediation to turn it over to a third party and have them settle the question
to Corinthians.
Turn that down.
I think that alone indicates,
uh,
who wanted war and who wanted peace at this point.
Um,
the other thing is that a,
mmm,
it should be remembered that the 30 years peace provided that neutrals,
we're free to join eva side that had signed the 30 years piece so that when they
were implying and threatening and alliance with Athens,
they understood that the Athenians were free to accept them into the alliance
without breaking the 30 years.
That would be a considerable issue.
As the problem grow is more difficult.
Well,
there is no peace.
And so the two sides organize their navies.
The Corinthians did not have a large standing Navien peacetime and they set to
work to put one together.
In four 35,
there is the battle of Luke Kidney,
which takes place between the Corinthians and the uh,
um,
of course the Koreans and the course of marines when
current is not deterred.
Now they really go to work and they build for them a vast fleet consisting of 90
ships,
unprecedented outside of Athens.
And they do turn not enough in an official way,
but unofficially to their Peloponnesian allies asking them to contribute help
too.
And they're Peloponnesian allies and another 60 ships.
And so the Corinthians have available a total of 150 ships.
The core,
the core Syrian sleep consisted of 120 ships.
They did have a fleet that they kept at all times and that had given them the
confidence in advance to do what they had done.
But here was Carmen's suddenly outnumbering them in this way of Coursera was now
thoroughly frightened.
They knew that Corinthians would be coming after them again with a fleet that
was bigger than theirs.
So they went to Athens in September of four 33 and now I ask you again to
imagine yourself sitting there on the picnics in Athens in September for 33
whereas the,
of course the Regan ambassadors have come to your town.
They're going to ask you to join in an alliance with them for the purpose of
fighting the Corinthians and their friends.
The Corinthians who have heard about this scent ambassadors of their own to
Athens.
They are present on that same hill and they will make their case as to why the
Athenians should say no to that request to acidities reports.
His version of both speeches is every reason to think.
He was sitting there in the Athenian Assembly on the days in which these
discussions took place.
The essence of the course,
serene argument is that,
well,
here are the,
here are the points they made.
Corrine's is wrong.
It is not a breach of the 30 years' peace for Athens to accept the course of
marines into their alliance because neutrals are permitted.
Then they go through a lot of stuff to show that the Corinthians are bad guys
making arguments on the grounds of a morality and virtue and decency and obeying
the law and all kinds of stuff.
But it's clear that that's not what's on their minds.
They are talking about,
um,
uh,
basically they tried to convince the Athenians on the grounds of the
significance of their decision for the balance of power and essentially the
balance of naval power in the Greek world.
They,
in passing,
they make the point that of course Syrah is very well situated for a naval or I
sh I mean for a sea voyage to Sicily in Italy where the Athenians and others are
always wanting to go,
so you want to be on our side.
That's not really a very potent argument because no town,
no polis shuts its ports to any other polis except in war time.
So it's only when they mentioned that they only have to be talking about why
it's valuable to be allied with Coursera because,
and this is their most powerful underlying argument.
There's going to be a war.
Don't kid yourself.
Athenians is what they are saying.
And when that war comes,
you're going to want to be us.
You're going to want to have us on your side.
In part because of our convenience,
our strategic location.
On the other hand,
more powerful is the fact we have 120 ships.
If those 120 if we lose,
if you let the Corinthians beat us,
our ships will fall into their hands and then they will have a much mightier
fleet than even the one they have put together.
And now your unquestioned dominance of the sea will be challenged.
That's what's at issue.
And don't imagine that this is just uh,
anybody's imagination.
This is going to happen.
The war is coming.
An enormous amount of what's happening here has to do with your perception of
whether war is now inevitable and whether or whether by by restraint you can
preserve the peace.
That's the problem that the Athenians face.
It's a terribly interesting one because it happens so very often on the brinks
of wars when that's the issue that determines what people will do or uh,
and how they react if they don't think that taking a certain action or I'm sorry
cause they don't think the war is coming anyway.
They may very well decide to refrain from an action that might provoke a war.
If on the other hand,
they think war is coming,
they,
they feel that it's too dangerous not to make our capacity to win the war more
likely.
And so they may well take a step which makes the war more likely,
uh,
and they're both gambles.
Nobody knows for sure one way or another you have to make an estimate.
And that's always the way it is.
Unless you are simply an aggressive state and all you want to do is conquering.
You don't care anything about anything else.
You're always trying to figure out will it be safer to fight or not to fight?
Will it be safer to try to make a concession or will that make it more
dangerous?
Those are always the issues,
always the problems.
One of the great in facilities that I discover all through my life as people
contemplate going to war at different times in our time is the quiet assumption,
unquestioned,
unexamined,
that restraint,
the failure to take action is safe.
Taking action is dangerous.
Whereas our experience,
even in my lifetime has demonstrated that's often wrong.
Nothing could be clearer to me.
And I think to most people who have studied the subject that not acting against
Hitler as he took one step after another to rip up the piece of hearing,
what's the most dangerous thing they could possibly do,
far more dangerous than confronting him early as early as 1936 when he invaded
the Rhineland.
And that's not the only case of it does that.
There's no simple rule.
Sometimes it's wise or not to act and sometimes it's wiser to act,
but it's never clear which one is more likely to produce peace and safety.
And that's what the Athenians had to wrestle with.
Uh,
on that day,
the Corinthians responded to the argument of the course of Reince denying their
picture of things.
They said,
in fact,
if you sign up with the,
uh,
of course regions now you will be in violation of the 30 years' peace.
What they were saying,
I guess in the abstract was don't worry about the letter of the law of the
treaty because that clearly permits an alliance,
the spirit that counts.
They said,
surely nobody imagined that this decision would be made at a time when one of
the people who are the neutral is asking you to join in was already at or with
one of us.
Surely nobody had that in mind.
There's certainly right,
nobody did.
The question is on the legal points.
My guesses the Athenians had the better the argument it says in black letter law
it says,
you may take a neutral if neutral asks you for in the lions there's nothing that
says,
except that when that neutral is attacking us didn't say that.
On the other hand,
who in his right mind could imagine it would be okay to do that.
So that was one issue that the Corinthians spoke to.
Um,
but they,
they made another point that was legalistic as well.
And this one,
I think the crisis,
the Corinthians is much worse.
They said the principle established in the 30 years piece was that each side
could punish its own allies without the interference of the other side.
Now,
as a matter of fact,
it didn't say that.
But the other thing that's wrong with that statement is it's one thing for
Athens to punish Samos,
which is an ally and ask,
and the Corinthian st fine,
that's your business.
We want intervene.
But Car Syrah is not the ally of current.
In fact,
they are bitter enemies of yesteryear.
There's no part of that treaty that protects the Corinthian right to a tech
salary.
So it's a great argument if you don't look at the validity of the facts that are
alleged.
Carmen's got a very bad case here,
but they're really important argument.
Is this a currency?
The cursory in say the war is inevitable?
Well isn't.
If the fact is they tell them if he means if you were smart,
the thing you would do would be to join us and together we'll smash the course
serines and then there's no more problem.
Uh,
but if you don't do that,
at the very least refrain from joining them because then we will be friends and
then we will have peace in the future.
But make no mistake about it.
If you do accept,
of course the range into your alliance now,
then there will be war.
War is not inevitable,
but your action can make it inevitable.
So that's what the Athenians confront when they have to make their decision.
Again,
I,
the drama of this is so striking.
I want to be sure you conceive of it.
They are sitting there.
All,
everything I've told you so far has been said on the same day.
And now the Athenian start talking about what should we do?
It's the same day.
The people who are sitting on the panics,
if the day is clear as they used to be in Athens,
just about every day can look out across an Attica to the north.
And they can see that area into which the Sparkman and Peloponnesian army,
we'll march and start destroying their farms three days from now.
But possibly if a war starts and who is going to be doing that,
fighting out there,
we will.
Those of us who were sitting here voting whether to go to war or not,
uh,
I'm always struck by the immediate,
the immediacy and the,
the significance of what these guys were doing.
Somebody tell me this is not a democracy please.
So it is of course the same kind of thing they faced back in [inaudible] 61 when
they had to decide whether to take a mega into the alliance.
Again,
there are significant differences,
but the issue is very much the same.
They can't be sure.
Maybe if they back off and refuse the alliance,
maybe that will be the end of the problem and they'll live happily ever after.
On the other hand,
if they're wrong about that and the Corinthians to take over this fleet,
suddenly they will find themselves vulnerable in a way they have not been since
they put their empire together.
I always find it illuminating to me anyway.
And I hope to you as well to make an analogy to Great Britain at the end of the
19th and the beginning of the 20th century,
Great Britain at the beginning of the 19th,
a sort of in the middle and after in the 19th century came,
we had the greatest navy in the world without question.
It was the greatest power in the world who had this enormous empire that ruled
and it,
uh,
it looked,
um,
its,
its vulnerabilities were mainly against France and Russia who were to imperial
rivals in the areas that the British cared about most.
And they typically,
they,
at a certain point,
they decided to make their fleet to be the size of the next two fleets put
together in order to feel secure in case a war broke out.
And that's what they did.
Everything was fine until Kaiser William becomes the emperor of Germany.
And the,
towards the end of the 20th of the 19th century decides that Germany must be a
great naval power,
must be a world empire.
It must challenge Britain for that,
uh,
Opportunity.
And they begin to build a fleet of battleships whose only purpose can be to
destroy the British fleet and to allow the Germans to invade Britain and
thereby,
or best of all to intimidate the British,
uh,
into stepping aside and allowing the Germans to do what they want to do.
As soon as the,
this becomes clear to the British,
as soon as the Germans start building that sleep,
it is not yet strong enough to defeat the British fleet and the British enter
into a naval race to see to it that they don't get to be big enough to take out
the British fleet.
But,
uh,
it's very costly.
The British don't like it and they try to find every way they can and what they
do is completely flipped their diplomacy,
which has dominated their behavior for over a hundred years and they make an
alliance with France and Russia to see to it that the Germans are checked and
prevented from doing what they're planning to do.
I think that does help to understand what the,
what the Athenians are doing when you are as in the case of Britain and Ireland
state as in the case of Athens,
you might as well be an island state because you are dependent on imports for
your food supply and the command of the seas essential for acquiring that.
In such a case,
it is not an a light thing to permit a change in the naval balance of power
which may make you seriously vulnerable in case of war.
The point I want to make is that the British didn't wait until the Germans had
equal therefores.
They changed their policy and ultimately moved into war to prevent it and that's
where the Athenians I think found themselves.
It was something they were not willing to do,
but it was a very hard call and we are told that they argued so long that it got
dark before the decision could be made.
A through acidity says it was thought that they were inclining against the
alliance.
When it got dark,
they met again the next day.
And this time they voted for something a bit different from what they had been
talking about the day before.
What the,
uh,
court,
of course [inaudible] had been requesting was a typical alliance.
The only kind we know of between Greeks,
a summa HIA and offensive and defensive alliance.
It would have required the Athenians to,
uh,
go out and fight the Corinthians,
even if the Corinthians didn't attack.
Of course,
Iran,
it would have put them fully at war against the Corinthians.
That's not what the Athenians voted on the second day.
They voted on the proposition that they establish something called an Epi Mahia,
which means a defensive alliance only.
They would only fight against an enemy.
With that enemy had attacked of course,
Syrah and was in the process of landing on their territory.
And so that's finally what the Athenians did.
That was the vote.
They joke,
once again,
we have something unheard of before a,
a device,
which is the way largely a diplomatic device meant to have consequences on
thinking rather than immediate military results.
So I say it's got to be cliche but I feel better this time because Plutarch's
says it was Paris,
please.
Even though you said it,
he's doesn't say who made that proposal.
It was a clearly what Pericles has wanted to because he holds to it very,
very firmly in both directions,
both in terms of the limits that this puts on Athenian action but on the
determination to take that action no matter what.
What I suggest to you is that we are going to be dealing from here on him.
We've been dealing with in a general way anyway,
but now it's very clear.
This is Perry please policy.
I assert it is a policy intended to keep the peace
and here again we run into a problem in our own time in which sort of the normal
reaction of people is if you want to keep the peace,
what you want to do is to be a nice guy.
What you want to do is to make concessions.
You want not to frighten the potential enemy you want to show that you have no
ill will towards him and then reason will prevail and you can all have a nice
chat and go off for tea.
Of course,
that's not the way it is at all.
One way always that has been used by nations in the hope of keeping peace is the
opposite device of deterrents where there isn't any hope of coming to a happy
agreement because if there had been you wouldn't be in the spot you're in now,
all you can do is try to indicate to your opponent that he will not achieve the
goals he seeks if he launches a war against you,
and so that requires that you be very strong,
militarily strong and strong in the way in which you negotiate.
On the other hand,
if that is your goal,
the deterrence,
then you also want to be very careful not to behave in such a way that is too
frightening,
that indicates to your opponent that you are likely to defeat him if he allows
you to be as strong as you would like to be.
You want to,
uh,
um,
be avoid taking an action that will make him lose his rationality,
that will make him so angry that he will forget about these questions of,
uh,
success and failure.
He'll just say,
I'm going to get that son of a gun.
And then I argue is the policy that [inaudible] pursuit and attempt at
deterrence and moderation at the same time to frighten the opponent by his
determination out of thinking that can do what they want without a danger of
war,
but also to avoid inflaming is a anger
in the short run.
What happens is that the Athenians send to assist their pell of there.
Of course we in our lies a fleet of only 10 triremes there.
This is in explicable in my view,
except in terms of this,
the strategy that I have suggested,
what he's is sending,
really not a forest,
but a diplomatic message.
He is telling the Corinthians,
you have been counting on the fact that we would stay out of this.
Well,
you were wrong.
We will not allow you to defeat the course Suria navy because we find that
unacceptable and dangerous.
So we're sending this force to help the core Syrians,
not because we want to fight you,
but because we want you to see that was serious about this.
Don't start the fight.
Well,
the Corinthian sale air fleet against course Syrah and their follows a battle at
sea called the battle of Sib Bota and two cities describes the battle itself.
Very tough battle.
The Athenians are,
I'm sorry,
I haven't told you one thing you need to know.
Um,
the Athenians will line up on one end of the Corinthia,
the course in line with their 10 ships.
The commanders of that fleet are determined as well.
Those 10 ships are commanded by three generals.
That's a lot of generals with potential.
But one of them who is the chief figure there is lasted diammonium [inaudible]
the son of Cayman.
Well,
of course,
he is clearly seen by everybody else as not one of Parak pleases boys,
not a stooge of Paris.
[inaudible] he's an independent.
And what does,
what's his name mean?
Mr Spartan.
Now if the Athenians get drawn into that battle and the command that we should
do so is done by less than diammonium,
then of course that will not have the effect of dividing the Athenians,
but it will make it much harder to divide.
The Athenians will be much easier to say all Athenians,
even those who have the kindest attitude toward Sparta thought that this was a
necessary step,
which I think was aimed not at Corinthians so much.
It was aimed of course at Athenian politics,
but I think it was aimed at the Spartans too,
because then if the Spartans were then asked by the Corinthian,
so look what happened,
come in and help us against the Athenians.
They would have to face the fact that even lasted diammonium thought this was
necessary.
It's the same game.
All of these are cagey moves by [inaudible] to pursue his extremely complicated,
tricky kind of a strategy.
And I see that I have run over my time,
so I'll pick up the tail next time.